après sept longs mois d'attentes
laurence pas phare est enfin réunie avec
son amoureux l'australien adam koenig et
les retrouvailles sont remplis d'émotion
soulagement beaucoup d'excitation
beaucoup de bonheur leur réunion était
impossible jusqu'à ce que le
gouvernement fédéral annonce des
assouplissements pour les couples en
mesure de démontrer qu'ils sont dans une
relation amoureuse exclusive depuis plus
d'un an
une séparation qui leur a semblé
interminable de stress voudrez mais
encaisse beaucoup de remises en question
certaines remises en question beaucoup
d'attenté beaucoup de déception aussi
parce qu'il ya tellement d'incertitudes
ademe a déposé sa demande d'autorisation
de voyage dès l'ouverture du processus
d'exemption et six jours plus tard il a
été l'un des premiers à l'appeler ni
crds de l'exercice faux excessivement
est chanceux on est très reconnaissant
vraiment c'est comme un coup de chance
comme si on avait gagné dans le prix
mais justement tout le monde n'a pas la
même chance
l'avocate marie hélène giroux est plongé
dans ses démarches d'exemption pour son
propre conjoint et pour des clients et
elle déplore la lourdeur et la lenteur
des démarches
le processus est opaque il ya un manque
de communication et une complexité d'un
processus inutiles
le porte parole du ministre de
l'immigration indique que plus de quinze
mille demandes liées à ces
assouplissements ont été déposée et
qu'une source is a été traité jusqu'à
présent ce qui est trop lent selon m
giroux non ce sens un peu trahie mais
par le gouvernement parce que le
processus ne semble pas fonctionner et
les gens commencent à se demander ce que
le gouvernement finalement au pot demi
ce processus lent placer l'europe
particulièrement difficile justement
pour décourager les gens deviennent d'y
avoir recours
la franco ontarienne samantha comeau
elle a vécu des émotions en montagnes
russes depuis le début de la pandémie
j'étais allé voir juste avant que la
pandémie je suis revenu au canada d'être
3 mars
je pense que le 15 mars la frontière a
été fermée et le vin marges ainsi que
j'ai tant de faim elle a passé toute sa
grossesse seul loin de tim son conjoint
américain ça l'était a nettement une des
pires expériences de ma vie comme je le
souhaiterais pas à mon pire ennemi
samantha a elle aussi trouvé le
processus d'autorisation de voyage
stressant et imprécis mais son conjoint
l'a finalement obtenu après 13 jours
d'attenté
je me sens un peu comme je peux respirer
finalement de savoir qui va être l'heure
pour la naissance de notre fille
merci beaucoup laurence et adem parts le
coeur léger
mais samantha elle ne sera pas rassuré
par son amoureux ne sera pas finalement
à ses côtés ici fanny bussières mcnicoll
radio canada montréal